fait partie du jeu fait partie du comité
national de transition écologique c'est
l'instance de dialogue environnemental
installé par ce gouvernement il ya le
medef il ya l'association des maires de
france l'association des régions de
france les parlementaires les
associations donc et l'état quand cette
consultation locale a été proposée par
manuel valls est idéal à l'unanimité à
l'unanimité on a dit non
les pros aéroports comme les anti
aéroport à l'unanimité le projet de
consultations locales proposée par
manuel valls a été rejeté par le
commission laquelle le comité national
de transition écologique ce qui se passe
maintenant à nantes c'est ce que nous
disons depuis des années ce que va
traiter le tribunal le tribunal a mis le
tribunal de grande instance est de dire
est ce qu a dit le rapporteur la
rapporteur public
c'est seul et les arrêté d'autorisation
des travaux sont incompatibles avec la
loi loi sur l'eau loi sur les espèces
protégées et ce qu'elle a dit
ce que nous disons depuis le début de
cette lutte elle dit il est inconcevable
que ce projet que l'alternative qui est
une obligation ya la légalité qui va
peut être être contestées ldc la
légitimité
cl j'en ai fait random locale mais je
viens de vous dire que la consultation
vous le savez on nous l'avons dénoncée
au jour 1 de la consultation
je vous ai dit que même les pros
aéroport notre dame des landes dans le
cadre du dialogue environnemental ce qui
doit justement décidé de ce type de
processus
elle avait rejeté à l'unanimité la mad
men en europe ecologie les verts mais on
a toujours dit que on a toujours dit que
celle ci constitue la station va faire
était biaisé dès le départ vous comptez
c'est la raison vous savez qu'on a
contesté la question on avait en même
temps quand même
c'est quand même le bazar on avait en
même temps madame royal qui commanditait
un rapport qui disait comme la
rapporteur public travaillons sur
l'aéroport actuel dernière lorsque vous
voyez que dans un livre de confidences
françois hollande lui-même dit qu'il
pense que cet aéroport ne se fera pas ça
serait bien qu'ils le disent une fois
bien qu'il une fois qui une fois devant
vous
et moi en tant que citoyens intelligents
on essaye de lettres qui plutôt que de
parler à des journalistes et de dire
l'inversé quand il passe c'est en vo
médias que y profite je l'espère de la
décision de justice pour mettre fin à
cette histoire absurde qui n'a que trop
duré thion est ce que sur ces questions
écologiques et environnementales est ce
que vous voyez en france l'équivalent
d'un donald trump et je suis très
inquiet que le parti
les républicains quand j'ai entendu les
déclarations de luc chatel de ce que
fait wauquiez dans sa région et de ce
qu'il dit de nicolas sarkozy devienne à
l'image du pis en pologne et des
républicains aux états unis deviennent
un parti anti écolo s'est pas seulement
un parti qui arrête de parler de la
protection de l'environnement
je suis très inquiet et je regrette
profondément sarkozy avait mis un gros
coup avec avec le grenelle ii vous les
traitez pas de fous que tout à l'heure
comme donald trump
non attendez ça c'est quand même une
différence d'accord et à la grèce est
notée bord mais je regrette profondément
mais je suis inquiet je suis très
inquiet par l'évolution des républicains
sur ce sujet